[موسيقى]
مع الوصول إلى أطباق جانبية وافرة
وأوقات الوجبات الخفيفة التي تلتزم
بالنظام الغذائي الصحي يمكن أن يكون صعبًا ، لكن من الممكن أن تكون
الخطوة الأولى هي الحد من تلك
الأطعمة ذات السعرات الحرارية العالية وتملأ طبقك
بالخضروات الموسمية الكثيفة مثل
البطاطا الحلوة أو براعم بروكسل.
البطاطا الحلوة غنية  يحتوي كلاهما على ألياف البوتاسيوم
وفيتامين أ ، بينما تحتوي براعم بروكسل على
نسبة عالية من فيتامينات الألياف K و C ،
يمكن أن يساعدك كلا هذين النوعين من الأطعمة على البقاء ممتلئًا
لفترة أطول ، ويمكن لمقايضة الزبدة بالزيت الذي يحتوي على نسبة
منخفضة من الدهون المشبعة أن يخفف
الخبز ، جرب زيت زيتون الكانولا أو زيوت فول الصويا.
يمكن أن تكون الزيوت مثل الأفوكادو أو بذور العنب خيارات صحية أيضًا ولكن
قد تكلف أكثر أو يصعب
العثور عليها ،
حافظ على نكهة فطيرة اليقطين مع
بارفيه الزبادي بفطيرة اليقطين باستخدام
الزبادي اليوناني كأساس لهذا العلاج يمكن أن
يقلل محتوى السكر الزبادي اليوناني
معبأ أيضًا  مع البروتين
والكالسيوم الضروريين لصحة جيدة حتى
مع الإغراء في كل منعطف ، يمكنك
الانغماس في الأطعمة المفضلة لديك والاستمرار في
تناول الطعام  مع القليل من التخطيط
[موسيقى]